بدلا من اتساع ومسح اوكرانيا من الخارطه
فقد واجه امه
اصبحت اشد من اي وقت سبق اوكرانيا باتت
الشهاده لشجاعه الامه والتي لن تتوانى
ابدا عن سعيها لتحقيق الحريه لقد شهدنا
ذلك في كل يوم من بين 365 يوما منذ اندلاع
هذه الحرب المريعه
تماما كما تقف استونيا بكل فخر كدوله
مستقله وحره فان اوكرانيا ستنتصر اوكرانيا
ستنتصر لان الاوكراني هنا لن يتراجعوا
ابدا واوكرانيا ستنتصر لان اوروبا
وشركائها وحلفائها سيقفون بكل قوه الى
جانبها
عام الحرب لا تزال مستعره
وصعد بوتين من المخاطر فقد ارسل مئات
الالاف من الروس الشباب
كوقودي حرب الى اوكرانيا ما شهدناهم اطلع
هذا الاسبوع من موسكو يوضح لنا من انهم مع
تراكم الخسائر على ارض المعركه فكذلك
يزادوا ياسا ووهمه ومعلوماته المضلله وهذا
يظهر الضغط الذي يواجهه نظام بوتين ولكنه
ايضا ياتي مع مخاطر حقيقيه وجديده
لاوكرانيا
فقد حان الوقت لمضاعفه جهودنا يجب ان
نستمر بتوفير اوكرانيا عن نفسها الى ان
ينهي روس هذه الحرب ويغادر اوكرانيا ولهذا
السبب نحن نقف في قوه الى جانب اوكرانيا
باكبر من اي وقت سبق لدعم اوكرانيا اما
اليا واقتصاديا وعسكريا ولزياده قدراتنا
الدفاعيه
لزياده الضغط على روسيا ومساءلتها
روسيا باتت اكثر عزله وتزداد عزلتها وكما
ثمنها في التصويت في الامم المتحده 141
دوله
صوتت لصالحه
القرار الذي يديني روسيا وروسيا
تراجع الى
اقتصاد مقطوعه عن العالم
وعقوباتنا تؤثر عليهم بشده
وتمنع اي حظوظ من تحديثه وسوف نستمر بفرض
هذه العقوبات على روسيا وكل ما يدعمهم على
ارض المعركه وسنستمر ملاحقه اتباع بوتين
وهؤلاء الذين يساعدون روسيا
لتجنب العقوبات او لتعزيز ترسانتها
العسكريه وفي نفس الوقت نعمل لضمان
مرونه اوكرانيا العسكريه والاقتصاديه اولا
باستمرار الدعم
المالي 67 مليار دولار حشدناها الى الان
وثانيا
مع زياده الدعم العسكري نهدف الى تدريب
ثلاثين الف جندي اوكراني في الاتحاد
الاوروبي
والدول الاعضاء يقدمون المعدات العسكريه
وسوف نقوم بعمليه شراء مشتركه
للمعدات العسكريه الطارئه الاوكرانيه مثل
ذخيره 155 ملم
وعلى نفس قدر الاهميه هي العمل مع صناعتنا
الدفاعيه
لتعزيز دفاعي لهذه الذخيره والمعدات
الاخرى المطلوبه من قبل القوات الاوكرانيه
وكذلك لتعزيز مخزوننا
انت محقق
هو في المجلس الاوروبي الاخير نحن بدانا
العمل واخيرا
هذه المسالات تخص فقط الانتصار على ارض
المعركه الاوكرانيون يقاتلون من اجل حقهم
لاختيار مستقبلهم
وسبق وان اختاروه لقد اختاروا الاتحاد
الاوروبي
لقد اختاروا وحده المبادئ كما ذكر الرئيس
الجنود على اوكرانيا يقاتلون في بخموت
يدافعون عن وحده المبادئ هذه وفي هذه
الاوقات المظلمه فان قلوب الشعب الاوكراني
تدفعها
الثقه من اوكرانيا ستنضم الى اتحاد
الاوروبي يوما ما
فهكذا تصيغ المبادئ الجغرافيه العزيزه
كايا اليوم انا فخوره للوقوف الى جانبك
وانت ينسى قتال للاحتفال
بحريه واستقلال استونيا
وانا فخوره لقفنا هنا معنا لدعم الشعبي
الاوكراني وقتالهم من اجل الحريه
والاستقلال
وانا على يقين باننا مثل شعبي اوكرانيا
فان اوكرانيا ايضا ستنتصر شكرا
تهانينا لكم على استقلال او في يوم ذكرى
استقلاليه ستانيا
يسرنا الى جانبكم هناك في هذا اليوم
على قبل مئه عام عن الجنود قاتل بكل
الشجاعه من اجل حريتهم واستقلالهم
الاستقلال لم يحضر بلا فتره قصيره ولكن
الشعب اللساني لم يستسلم ابدا وعما سقوط
الستاره الحديديه
استعدتم حريتكم اشكركم جزيلا لدعوتي
للمشاركه
باحتفالاتكم اليوم
هو احتفالي رفع العالم
كلها كانت مؤثره
وعبرت عن تقديركم لحريتكم
تاريخكم تذكار قوي من اننا لا يمكن ان
ناخذ الحريه على محمل
او انها امر مسلم
هي ليست مجانيه ويجب ان قاتل مجدها في كل
يوم والشعب الاوكراني اليوم يقاتل بكل
شجاعه من اجل حريتهم وعلى الرغم من عام
مظلم من الياس والدمار فان عزيمتهم
وشجاعتهم بلا شك ستنتصرا قبل عام الرئيس
بوتن يشنق غزوه الشامل ضد اوكرانيا هذه
حرب عدائيه غير قانونيه وبنتهاك صارخ
لقواعد الدوليه اراد ان يكسر اراده الشعب
الاوكرانيين واراد ان يكسر وحدتنا الرئيس
بوتين
اوكرانيا تقف صامده والناتو والاتحاد
الاوروبي يقفان الى جانب اوكرانيا
ومع ذلك فان بوتين لم يتخلى عن اهدافك فهو
يريد اوروبا مختلفه
تحدد روسيا ما يقوم به او تقوم به دول
الجوار هو ليس مستعد للسماء
للسلام بل يعيد المزيد من الحرب فيجب ان
نزود اوكرانيا ما تحتاجه من اجل انتصار
دعمنا الى اوكرانيا
فيه مجازفه صعيد ولكن لا توجد اي خيارات
من دون مخاطر واكبر خطر او مجازفه هي اذا
من انتصر الرئيس بوتين لان الرساله التي
سبعتها الى القاده المستبدله الاخرين انهم
يستطيعون استخدام القوه للحصول على ما
يرغبون به وهذا سيجعل العالم اكثر خطوره
ويجعلنا نحن اكثر ضعفا
فدعم اوكرانيا
ليس فقط الشيء الاخلاقيه الصحيح بل يصب
ايضا في مصلحتنا الامنيه
ولهذا السبب فان حلفاء الناتوي يوفرون
دعمًا غير مسبوق الى اوكرانيا ويعملون
جنبا الى جانب مع الاتحاد الاوروبي
مره اخرى استونيا قدوه
توفر المزيد من الدعم العسكري من حصه نادي
محل الاجمالي اكثر من اي دوله اخرى
تواجد ان يحمل الفضاء للحلفاء لتوفير هذا
الدعم منذ 2014
وقمنا بتعزيز تواجدنا وجاهزيتنا بشكل كبير
من البحر الاسود الى بحر البلطيق من ضمنها
هنا في استونيا
المجموعه القتاليه
التي تقودها المتحده تردع الاعتداءات
المقاتلون من فرنسا والمانيا يساعدون
بحمايه سمائكم
وبمساعده اسبانيا السيد نزول من الدعم
الدفاع الجوي كل هذه تبعت رساله واضحه الى
موسكو ان ستحمي وتدافع عن استونيا وكل
بوصه من اراضي الناتوك التزامنا
قوي وصارخ
الواحد للجميع
والجميع الالواحد في القمه
اضافيه لتعزيز دفاعنا المشترك
كما نرى تقدما فيما يخص
الضمير فنلندا والسويد الى حل فينا دوله
المجاورتان الى استونيا
صادقوا على بروتوكولات الضم
عقدته نقاشات جيده مع رئيسه
واتفقنا على اعاده بدء المحادثات
والاجتماعي
والسويد وتركيا في مقر الناتو في منتصف
مارس تحت رعايه لمناقشه تطبيق
الاتفاق الذي عقدناه في ليونيل الماضي
وكيفيه اكمال عمليه الضم
البرلمان الحنجاري سيبدا بعمليه المصادقه
في الاسبوع الماضي القادم وهدفنا لفنلندا
والسويد ان تنضماني في اسرع وقت
هذا سيعزز
امن اوروبا
وكذلك الناتو
شكرا مره اخرى على هذه الحوارات الجيده
والتزامكم
بالتعرف عبر الاطلسي واذا تابعنا الكرام
جزء من هذا المؤتمر الصحفي
لينسز
المفوضيه الاوروبيه اكدوا بان الحرب لا
تزال مستعره وروسيا مستمره فيها وبان حرب
روسيا عدائيه وغير قانونيه وبان انتصار
بوتين في هذه الحرب اكبر خطر على امن
النيتو